on that when you bring first your time
and talent and now your treasure to this
institution and to the other
organizations that you support are you
also bringing a vision of what you would
like Yale to do or what you would like
the role to be for this catalyst if
ye'll is a catalyst in the world or are
you more of a passive investor in
whatever it is the organization is doing
well I actually think that when I give
money it's probably the latter that I
fine I got tired of giving ten dollars
here and there every time somebody asked
me for something so I decided to really
direct it and I looked for things that I
thought looked for organizations i
thought we're doing a really great job
that's something that I cared about and
in because I think they're doing a
really great job I will give them my
money and you know let them do whatever
they need to do with it and that that
includes Yale in terms of my yell giving
actually occasionally I'll direct it
within the university I used to always
in fact I still do direct my sort of
annual you know sort of basic level of
giving to financial aid you can do that
when you give your that's one of the
boxes you can check and then for my
reunion gift I gave it to the the new
library you know so there were specific
things that I thought that's great I
want to support that thing but I think
in terms of the time again there is this
sort of you know loop that gets created
of feed you know positive feedback to me
and then we keeping engaged with it and
because of the role that I've had being
on the board as you know and then being
the chair I've had a lot of ability to
direct what we do at the aya so you know
i'm not sure what my vision is for the
future but i think i was able to help
get to where we are now through having a
vision when I started out partly was
seeing deficits but apart Leigh it was
being able to visualize the
you know what we could become and it's a
lot about this connection and that we
really could get people to engage if we
let them tell us how